saudi Arabia's King Abdullah of Saudi
Arabia one of our biggest allies in the
Gulf
a which doesn't let women vote or drive
but at a different topic altogether
has introduced a series of new laws
which defined
atheist as terrorist at missus according
to a report from Human Rights Watch
and the the laws basically it come into
play
because the the growing number of Saudis
that are traveling to into Syria
to fight in the Civil War there and then
they're returning to Syria
with newfound part-time freedom and they
now have all these new
military skill and the monarchies
basically afraid that all these new
ideas
is gonna cause what's happening in Syria
to happen in saudi arabia
let's look at Royal Decree 44
criminalizes participating in
hostilities
outside the kingdom with prison
sentences between three and twenty years
article one of the new provisions define
terrorism as calling for
EPS thought in any form or calling into
question the fundamentals are the
Islamic religion on which
this country is bait I thought as a Star
Wars guy I thought it was funny that I
broiled the Cree 44 which sounds so much
like
order 66 which is where they killed all
the jet I but I'd
have to tell you do that Island okay
we've got to
28 the St right I mean I know you well
enough and I know your way
well 20 I am what the arcade with for
I don't believe that there's somebody up
there judging me but I believe in the
force basically but I don't think I
believe him either
I believe there's something happening
here that I can't really explain but I W
yeah
odiaun even got I don't think I cared
how much I jerk off
alright alright alright I think he's mad
like a a yeah
God where you work all that I created
this little universe and I was creating
some others 10
not watching leave it at that yeah that
the DS I think you'd be like
in trouble with right now D our Jarod
not be
programming to make it okay okay I am
so art to add APS is there a bit was
bonkers thing you've ever I love that I
can be a terrorist without doing
anything
for I know I am it was a really ATF
in the left the increased like it it
doing less than being religious
it didn't laugh a bully so literally
without doing anything making any
decisions having any
belief system or insights into anything
where terror but can it can you
understand why a monarchy the
that has so much control of their people
and as I said doesn't let women vote
or drive yet can you understand why that
in a weird way is more of a threat I can
sorta see why they'd
see that concept as more of a threat
than actually
terrorism United Way of course that is
the problem with
living under a theocracy is that you're
going to have legislation in place that
morally directed that fundamentally
based on
your specific religious values
and it going to you by its very nature
target individuals that don't fit into
that box and
you know look at what's happening right
now in Brunei with assault and overnight
past Sharia law in this country
minutes fucking insane like your I'd
much rather go
number of someone's hand now for all
feeling if I go to Brunei it like I will
be put to death in five minutes like I
will figure out how to break some sort
of law that will
you know they'd kill your execute
exactly
and so I I'd rather go to Saudi Arabia
but these are shades of shit
is what we're talking about right now
and yeah the way they are you boycotting
the Beverly hotel
because they've got the average Beverly
Hills Hotel because that owned by the
Sultan of Brunei have it I generally
spend a lot of money at the Beverly I
right you people wake up for me a but
yeah I mean
I think these are all say the same thing
you know if we talk about
a oppression of women and we talk about
oppression a baby estate values what
we're really talking about is that the
%ah kirstie
trying to maintain its religious values
which are patriarchy
and kind of core you know power in the
hands of the
rich in the hands of the people who who
can use
me kinda religious codes to control the
decisions that
the that lesser than than the I mean it
age-old story
it's depressing as shit that we're
living in 2014 and we're seeing this but
it doesn't surprise me that saudi arabia
make these decisions what pisses me off
is that they're a strong ally of America
same as Brunei by the way we're now I
have a country with Sharia law
and that's all because family also I bet
that that connecting I wanted to bring
other with I without getting into major
geopolitical discussion
do we have to reevaluate some a bar
alliances on some of these places that
such horrific human rights where they're
literally stoning gay people to death
and for the third time now women can't
boat and I mean it's such a fundamental
basic
simply America do we have to reevaluate
who were friends with
even though you had it gone apparently
like yeah I
I was actually going to pose that
question to you guys because it's like a
really touchy subject but
I find it hard to imagine that I'm in a
country that supporting
that type of environment people I feel
so bad I get messages from people all
the time
for Middle East and they're scared to
even write me a message
because if somebody were to see if they
could be executed yeah so for people to
have to live in that
our people were being killed because
they're gay like I just I just don't
understand why
we would you know use money as and I
have an incentive to support that type
environment
and that's the problem were so
entrenched in this kind of American
exceptionalism in this
political like whatever my country think
I think you that we actually use phrases
like
why do we support fucking support their
but my government does and that's
unfortunate for a lot of people
because it make us look on the world
stage
like we are willing to turn the other
way
a were willing to turn the it turn the
other way about the human rights
violations which we r
which week exactly and that's the real
problem I'm not
right but as as a nation we are in that
basically because of what you said it
that dependence on oil and I think that
if we got to a place where we
where left dependent on fossil fuel
and I'm not even about foreign fossil
fuels the fossil fuels in general and we
were really embraced a more green
movement which is helpful for
a million reasons it helpful to the
economy it helpful to the environment I
mean there's
only positive side effect of making
these decisions
we this won't even this will be a
conversation
Obama would immediately be like fuck you
guys want to give you eight anymore not
tell you
you know lift this ban or not until you
stop you know killing people for their
belief router even Obama is not about
politics I can't believe who were I
just a little bit like by Alaska's were
talking about atheism
what do you guys personally say to the
people that say there are no atheists in
foxholes
to the people that they are on on the
your deathbed you are going to retract
everything you believe and much more
shit
take a horrible that horrible I know
that Christopher Hitchens spoke a lot
about that whenever he was dying
yet he definitely didn't take back
anything that he said I think that
really an insult to your intelligence
saying
you obviously can't hold your beliefs
true because if you were in a situation
you throw it all away so you're
almost in a phase until you need
daughter religion or something and
that's just insulting to your character
and your intelligence yeah
it also putting such a strange onus on
the apfa we think like their
can believe everything they believe
they're tired to collect for general
raoul
it's just one more way for them if they
were right and you're wrong because one
day you're gonna agree with me
it sure this if we were raised in a
nation
where religion was never taught where
there was no cultural bias toward
religion
and then we went to war for our country
and then we found ourselves in a box all
we wouldn't makeup but not that I've got
like
were thirtieth by to fall off religion
is indoctrinated
into us so of course some people go back
to their
earlier mentalities because they were
raised that way but I don't know any
ABS who in the late stages of life who
were never exposed to religion who are
all the sudden like
I'm going to invent some sort of
religion as a as a means a feeling safe
and
and comfortable gonna bring that I've
met a lot of people who
are raising their kids about religion
and I've had a conversation with a kid
now like I just don't understand how
people think these crazy things you know
I don't believe in Santa Claus anymore
and I think it's really important that
people could just step back and imagine
that they never had that a doctor nation
imagine that they never
were brought up with religion an entire
self the religion story again whether
your Muslim or Christian or whatever you
are it would sound ridiculous
so I wanna ask those people who ask me
what I would do my deathbed wall
why on your deathbed argument start
praying to Allah yeah
you know you could be wrong might as
well cover all the bases yeah
that you know a common thing that they
that they say kinda been a bf their
goals which is that
were all ABS I just go one God murder in
aa
up